cette circonscription de l'est côte-d'or
quand 76 communes le nord-est de dijon
saint-apollinaire auxonne ou encore
mirebeau sur bèze
au total près de 70 mille électeurs
répartis quasiment pour moitié entre
ville et campagne
rémy de la tse le député sortant il est
aussi le maire de saint-apollinaire
s'il est élu il devra choisir
conformément à la loi sur le non-cumul
président départemental du parti des
républicains en côte d'or une vrille ici
un troisième mandat associé à ludovic
rochette très attaché au terrain et ça
chacun de ses biens c'est un petit peu
ma marque de fabrique si je puis
m'exprimer ainsi ludovic rochette
également et puis vint soucieux de
défendre les intérêts de nos concitoyens
en particulier dans le contexte que nous
vivons après cinq ans de socialisme qui
nous ont conduit à une situation très
difficile au ps pierre pribetich a
soutenu emmanuel macron dès le lendemain
du premier tour de la présidentielle
tout comme françois rebsamen et
l'adjoint au maire de dijon
n'envisageait certainement pas qu'il est
un candidat de la république en marche
face à lui il n'est apparemment pas
rancunier c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire je suis dans une démarche
constructive pour permettre d'apporter
le concours des valeurs les principes de
gauche à la construction de cette
nouvelle majorité présidentielle qui
devra accompagner ce quinquennat
je souhaite la réussite de notre pays et
permettre à la france qu'elle puisse
prendre un nouvel élan
le seul et unique candidat estampillé la
république en marche le voici
même s'il est lui aussi adjoint au maire
de dijon françois de seuils encarté au
modem annonce la couleur et entend se
démarquer de son adversaire socialiste
moi je suis pour défendre des valeurs
nouvelles des hommes nouveaux
le revenu universel très peu pour moi
lui il a défendu leurs univers sel
premier tour moi jamais c'est la valeur
du travail la notion travail réf
aider les entreprises à embaucher c'est
pas du tout ça donc moi j'ai vraiment
l'intérêt c'est de créer une force
nouvelle autour d' emmanuel macron est
vraiment une bonne et une majorité forte
dans cette circonscription un électeur
sur deux vit à la campagne
franck gaillard candidat du front
national l'a bien compris et en cela il
suit point par point le programme de
marine le pen
si je suis élue députée je ferai en
sorte de de pouvoir promouvoir justement
cette rivalité de réinstaurer des
gendarmes et des médecins des maisons de
retraite dans ces zones
oubliez patricia marque et novice en
politique candidate de la france
insoumise cette enseignante espère être
présente au second tour
forte des 10 9% réalisée par jean luc
mélenchon ici à l'élection
présidentielle pour elle il est
important de faire barrage au projet du
nouveau président monsieur nacre on sait
c'est l'austérité à cesser les projets
européens c'est monsieur john kerr qui
décident de madame merkel qui décide et
nous nous proposons au contraire un
programme humaniste sociale écologique
surtout est ce qui a été ignorée et puis
démocratique en fait on veut rétablir la
démocratie c'est à dire le peuple doit
se promouvoir se prononcer
historiquement fief de droite cette 2e
circonscription pourrait réserver des
surprises
en commençant par une forte probabilité
de voir trois candidats ou peut-être
même 4 s'affronter au second tour et
voici les autres candidats qui se
présentent sur cette circonscription
delphine braillard pour lui père éric
copie divers droite christine legrand
jean du mouvement 100% fabrice grues et
des élèves catherine hervieu europe
écologie verts tata warraq du pcf est
claire rocher de lui tout rires